previously on raft what are we doing
some food with you this is a bit of an
exploration no there's got to be food on
it it's a yacht
I got a mechanical part requires one car
jack I can use one bomb how close do you
think I can be to this bomb when it goes
should I be away from this should I be
away from the Oh No
I've got a carry Bob to the bed all
right mark have fun exploring all right
cool thank you this last scrap gun notes
notes up DA's noose Oh blueprint for an
engine I want an engine a steering wheel
this is a good day find anything else
besides that oh there was food on here
fools I'm dead mark I need to be laid
gently in a bed you fool you're not dead
no I've seen dead and this is pretty
dead not dead he's still talking he's
not dead is that all is that all did you
get the whole boat was the engine the
only thing in the boat maybe just say
yes or no don't [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know did you open all the doors
that you had all the keys for didn't
know now you don't know I never knew
everything hmm
you knew a lot of things sounds like I
gave you guys all I had mmm we crafted
the bomb we got the car jack we used the
bolt cutters on something right yep I
have wires used to craft the bomb yeah
we yeah well we're looking the T in DLC
there's a recorder and two mechanical
parts left over I don't know what those
are for
Oh Balboa one one two six we do have
another we have another heading elbow
island so we're good we can go all right
um while we're here before we take off I
said we might need more copper I don't
know if we need more
there was another thing I looked
underwater there's nothing on this
island and I have copper do you need
copper I don't know what it takes to
craft an engine I know I know anymore
batteries uh let me look
we need to research the engine foyers
engine oh we can learn it right away
we're good I'm sorry that was uncalled
for
anybody got planks I need some planks
may have planks literally bursting out
of my anus can I not get the ones that
were in your anus can I all right
there's some in this box right here here
it looks like I will get to Swit I'm
scared about this engine to put it on
the edge wondering if I might be able to
like put it inside we should yeah we
should probably not put it on the edge
here let me I'm gonna move something
real quick oh my god holy [ __ ] no no
it's not even built yet I'm just trying
to figure out what nightmare place I'm
gonna put it how do you take away spots
yeah Aksum were where you want
oh no I I'm just yeah that'll do so I
just got a okay like that and then okay
you might want to stand back I want to
see this I'm ready and then the steering
wheel will be right here debate I'm
lighting your fire which way you're
trying to go my god I guess forward all
right and we're good we're gonna be so
fast maybe yeah I don't know look at
this thing turds I don't even know if
that counts is purple we're gonna need
so many planks then jeez
it requires plank yeah no holy geez yeah
but it's that's it's a hungry beast
what's our heading
so what's like that so the opposite
direction that we are operation art
rotating smoothly holy [ __ ] that's
actually pretty awesome oh my god well
that actually kind of ruins the
navigation system we had developed yeah
well dude what the Sun we could use the
Sun if we were true outdoorsman's you
and we are turning okay you're basically
done like a 270 degree turn oh [ __ ]
where you are right here I'll watch I'll
watch right yep you going keep going
keep going slow it up slow down going
slowing slowing going keep going keeping
going going going
locking traveling okay cool good wait I
understood machine
I stopped okay on target boy locked on
target baby don't look away for a second
I'm getting like nauseous from the
spinning seasick completed video kay I
feel like we should be going faster it
don't seem to be doing much yeah I want
to just load this [ __ ] up with planks
oh it is loaded with blanks
let me drop the sails see what that'll
do if it's any different
what does this mean mark what does this
marking mean 1 1 I think it's per one of
you links so I think if the raft grows
it gets it gets heavier yeah so do we
need multiple engines it's entirely
possible that's not good
look at economies of scale we'll get
more materials yeah the materials are
currently going in the direction where
it's tempting to travel faster than we
are
yeah they're floating away from us in
front of us that's not correct no maybe
maybe what do you know
not quite right well I mean the sale
should be doing something why is it not
doing anything because we're going into
the wind that's sound because I you and
your wind nonsense
yes all right I'll I don't know if I
have the mitrice to make another one
okay we need rope
we need circuit board I can make that
and then planks okay so I have the
planks in the rope
I need the circuit board and then I need
the ingots I only okay I got the ingots
for you too they're in the storage
they're all in there
then we'll be blasting then we will
absolutely Mourad our oh you even
constructed the the engine place thank
you sir mm-hmm incoming
skadoosh there we go I had got a hit all
right we're on our full speed ahead
currently oh it's dead I'm gonna get the
meat oh no I need more planks both
engines are not currently full speed
ahead all right well when we get this
weight it was off oh yeah oh my god but
the materials are due right of it where
are the materials over there hang on
okay they'll come they'll really
reconfigure yeah we should
we are absolutely chugalug in right now
dude I've never chugged so much lug as
we are chugalug I'm gonna compile our
condense our sails a little closer just
to give us a little more speed weigh
anchor there's a downright sailing ship
we have here it's I'd say no longer a
raft
we are officially seamen this is should
I tiniest little piece of crap Island we
could have gone to on purpose yeah but
what's underneath it is the question
hopefully lots of metal these engines do
dude life-changing zagoon abandoned you
on this island so much faster now what
oh my god mm it's shirk don't be like
and I was happy in the next minute my
feet was gone it was gone yeah I was on
her side then confusing I was on your
side I'm no longer on that's good
you were on my side - what - I open my
mouth till you used incorrect grammar
friendship with weight ended friendship
rammer it be what we thought I use
trying to be done why there's like no
iron I'm not seeing iron there's copper
there's a lot of copper but we don't
really need copper well we do four
batteries batteries mm-hmm
now the question of the day is can I
fire my bow underwater physics be damned
oh it's coming I see him dance buddy
boob chest if we don't know recipes
throw them into the sea don't just put
them in my food chest you animals what
no oh god I'm I die no uh there's no sea
weed here this is a terrible island like
the worst uh sometimes your Islands it's
garbage what are you gonna do not my
Island not my Island sometimes marks
Island is garbage not hashtag not my
Island all right I'm gonna get back to
building my - hi crow's nest here why do
you want rose nest because I wanted
crows that wouldn't what kind of
question even is that you're right
you're right I'm wrong why would you
want a crow's nest
I don't know mark why would you want me
to not slap you in the face with my big
meaty hands hands yeah how far away from
that point I've been without 100 meters
it's North Jesus good thing we got these
engines dude why you don't it's not even
a concern we are absolutely gonna crank
ass with these engines we also need to
find some better islands so we can get
aminals and stuff where are these better
Isla
are you talking about I might be so have
you looked at the thing in a while no I
haven't looked at the thing in the wild
why would I have looked at the thing in
the while I'm not a thing
I think this gross dope I was expecting
Bob but man you are right that is right
that is it's so dangerous what a minute
oh yeah these other islands obviously
these are the things that are gonna be
the things that have the things can we
put the steering wheel up here is that
possible yeah yeah we could I think you
can put it anywhere I'm not saying
that's a good idea
no yeah that's that's a good idea
because then you can turn in accordance
with the navigation right oh you mean on
the crow's nest like a greedy bastard
where you just want it up on you you
know oh yeah yeah I retract my that's a
good idea Santosh this is such a
dangerous place to be
so now cause everything oriented with
the edges dopey a psychopath no I'm
going to orient it with the navigation
so that it's pointed in there this is
the helmsman's position oh I can't help
you with the shark from up on my lofty
perch I'm sorry
good thing you have to stay up there at
all times we gotta we gotta get this
show on the road
get this show on the road let's go
alright so we going so the thing is I
will never turn these sails they are
always pointed forward in no direction
they're all pointed in different
directions you have to turn the boat do
you need the sock with that hell oh yes
I don't know the wheels under here for
my motorboat all right coming right
bring it to me I cannot come down no I
am coming alright you'll have to look at
this lower platform
excellent I have to come down from here
to give food don't die
yeah oh I'm sorry yes captain you have
to urge well you need to do is make a
chest next to you so that you can never
leave I can definitely fit a chest up
here I'm gonna build me more platforms
I'm just gonna put the chest on the very
edge mayhaps what if it is in the
adjacent spot no it has to be up here
with me climbing in any direction at all
is incredibly dangerous
hi captain how are the engines on fuel I
have no idea I don't see where fuel is
on the on the gauge on the Left showing
fuel amounts how fuel er there ones more
than half and ones near full oh right
what a time to be alive we're cranking
now we are indeed crane hey there's that
cruise ship why are we passing that
again wait what yeah
I'm so high up I can barely see it
that's how that's how high it works I
got the woods going away too fast come
back I can't hook it why is all of our
stuff off to the left what why do we
don't need what where what no as a shark
attack happening I miss I think I've
devised a method by which I can get down
from the steering wheel the ladder no I
think if I just jump all the way down to
the main deck one of you can fetch my
corpse lay me on the bed and I'll be
just fine
yeah no I can't can't argue with it that
is not a bad idea
more of our nets we're on the side of
the boat that was forward now yeah I'm
working you know you know mark can you
put more than that
that you mention it is so funny it's my
I think you should do that mark I had an
idea and I was so yes I captain aye aye
captain I felt like you know if you fall
under the ice and you just you know oh
god no no that's that's the net it's the
net flying I'll get up to the helm and
we can circle around for you didn't
throw though I wonder why would the net
of burst out of my inventory
come here no I'm busy changing the nets
I'm coming to right next to you wait
where does it mark so look at this right
what what see this this metal tube right
here yeah I see it
this connects all the way up to the
steering wheel that is impressive see
that you've made a girthy and sturdy
steering column my friend that's how I
do that's what I do that's when I do and
that's how I do it you know what mark if
there's a net missing on the
[Laughter]
Hey look we have room for more entrance
because some of the nets are missing I'm
I'm going insane and I'm building
another sail or 900 meters away from
whatever this blip is we plugged in oh
yeah baby is engines are running a
little low captain gotta fill them up
you're the captain boss i relinquish
that's not how being captain work I
relinquish a way to become not captain
is to die oral English you want to
become not that's the most threatening
[Laughter]
nine engines on this thing no freaking
whoa what whoa whoa what the [ __ ] what
the hell all I see is things in the sky
oh my god what the hell is it it's big
it's big it's bigger than big what the
hell it's big actually I think this is
where the dramatic ending you know I
don't know we have to be a little bit of
a cliffhanger it'll be like a
cliffhanger and look at those cliffs a
mark I don't want to tell you how to do
your job but I wish we had more nets on
the right side of the ship I got you
I'm just saying if you if you're gonna
dub your self the master of the net I
didn't I think that's at all if you're
gonna brag so much about how many nets
on your plate I really feel like there's
a huge imbalance between the front left
and front right parts of the ship boat
that goes you know far up here on this
ivory tower that I felt from my side I'm
gonna really [ __ ] that job of making
sure we have nets everywhere there's
cliffhangers
[Music]